a damn guy in um in tennessee blew up a
freaking uh an rv
a good rv the guy parked it out in front
of a hooters and damn blew it up
and twin peaks is better anyway and i
know and you know it
and i'm not trying to tell i'm not
trying to preach at you but i'm just
saying damn twin peaks is better
all the good you know tits
all those good you know them front bags
baby you feel me
all them freaking mmm the milky
headlamps they've all
migrated long ago over to um
twin peaks i mean really the only people
still working at hooters is orange
[ __ ]
let's be honest and no offense um
el perros
but that's the facts that's the only
people
still working at hooters
are mostly really teachers assistants
who are afraid to do only fans
and orange [ __ ] that's facts man
i just can't believe we that we're
making it this far and the world
it is getting unique out there
you know i mean some fella damn blew up
a rv a decent camper
okay that thing slept six honey
but in the end it slept one you feel me
but some man
kill bossed that [ __ ] over there
downtown in the central east out there
in tennessee
and he was lonesome it's it you know
there was a little
here and there he said something they
you know he
thought about lizard people or something
but you know he was probably listening
to a
tinfoil hat i have no idea but he you
know the guy
i mean it was a lonely dude that blew
himself up
and i'm not shocked
first of all it's hard to park down
there let's be honest downtown parking
who has not wanted to sometimes
when i'm downtown and i can't i'm
looking for parking i literally wish
that my glove box
was a little oven and i just want to put
my head on there
in there and go full blast honey
i want to set that [ __ ] on nine and
grill my thoughts because i'm damn angry
that's why
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been